[Musique]
toujours au direct de diversité des
mères à marly le roi on va aborder un
problème très grave et très important et
c'est peut-être pas comment le résoudre
c'est celui des déchets sauvages et pour
en parler les accueille philippe deiss
membres je vous êtes le maire de
méricourt vous êtes le président de
l'association des maires ruraux de
france 78 et marc bourrel vous êtes
maire de noisy le roi et vous nous
occuper ou à la communauté de versailles
grand parc de l'environnement et des
déchets problème grave je crois qu'en
france on peut donner quelques quelques
chiffres 80 mille tonnes de déchets
sauvages sont jetés chaque année c'est à
dire qu'ils ne vont pas dans les
quelques 4700 déchetterie qui sont là
pour les accueillir et dans les yvelines
il ya des problèmes voyait revenir
notamment l'office national des forêts
qui veut plus s'occuper de nettoyer la
forêt comment on explique aux faut que
les gens soient aussi j'allais dire ou
malveillants ou inciviques
c'est un phénomène qui tend à prendre de
l'ampleur
aujourd'hui et pour le coup c'est un
phénomène qui touche aussi bien les
communes rurales que les villes de
france pour une fois on a un sujet qui
est vraiment qui nous à vous êtes plutôt
d'innovation architecturale
je vais plutôt à la campagne alors
il ya plusieurs types de déposer un
dépôt sauvage il commence au chewing gum
aux mégots c'est le citoyen lambda et
après il ya le citoyen qui ne peut pas
trouver d'exutoire pour ses déchets
c'est à dire que je viens à la
déchetterie avec mes pneus par exemple
on ne les prend pas qu'est-ce que j'en
fais je les remets pas dans mon sous-sol
le gars il va les mettre dans la nature
ces exemples on allait beaucoup de
d'entreprise alors entreprises déclarées
ou pas ça on n'arrive pas à quantifier
mais dans tous les cas il ya pas oublier
aussi des entreprises voilà beaucoup de
déchets d'entreprise qu'on retrouve dans
la nature
là il ya un vrai sujet il n'y a pas de
déchetterie pro digne de ce nom
une entreprise qui doit faire 20 km et
payer une fortune pour mettre ces
déchets elle le fait pas elle les fait
pas voilà ça c'est un ça c'est un
problème l'accès aux déchetteries que ce
soit pour les particuliers ou les
professionnels pour les particuliers
c'est 5 km pour un professionnel c
maximum 10 km par rapport à son
entreprise et il faudra que l'on doit
quantifier sens d'un calcul et on sait à
peu près ce qu'on est au-delà gens sont
prêts à faire pour la légende fort ouais
parce que c'est déjà contraignant donc
voilà c'est tellement plus facile
d'aller déverser sa bordure d'un chemin
bien sur mac mac toral sur ce classique
nous on a également
ces problématiques alors on touche à la
fois on est un peu dans l périurbain
voilà mais on a sur l'ensemble de la
communauté d'agglomération de versailles
grand parc ses 2500 tonnes par an avec
quatre cent mille euros 500 à 1500
tonnes par an quatre cent mille euros
entre la collecte et le traitement donc
c'est un c'est un coup énorme
alors nous on a fait le choix sur nos
déchetteries d'accueillir les
professionnels bon même si c'est le cas
même si c'est même si c'est payant
et en terme en termes de nous on
raisonne en distance effectivement
philippe à raison pour nous plus de 15
minutes pour la une déchetterie c'est
mort il est mort donc on travaille aussi
nous on n'a qu'une seule déchetterie on
travaille sur un projet on va en ouvrir
une autre sur le périmètre de versailles
grand parc et un autre projet mais c'est
bien là on est on est au coeur de d'une
éventuelle solution c'est de proposer
des choses maintenant effectivement en
ville c'est le particulier de façon
volontaire ou involontaire
et puis nous on a la problématique je
suis maire de noisy le roi sur la plaine
de versailles
là ce sont les professionnels qui
profitent des grands espaces pour ben
pour lâcher leur leurs déchets de
chantier alors on pourrait dire il ya de
josiah un facteur d'éducation peut-être
souvent chez les particuliers
et puis une sorte de je m'en foutisme je
sais pas comment l'appeler aux fins de
huy deux pas de la part de certaines
personnes qui se disent ouais on profite
comme la de turin oui oui oui absolument
ni vu ni connu en plus il ya ça faut
dire aussi que les les élus sont sans
vraiment désarmé alors les bears vous
êtes le maire il a du mal à exercer son
pouvoir de police a déjà faut arriver à
les trouver
oui moi je sais que je les les pistes
sur ma commune je vais fouiller dans
l'état pourra essayer de retrouver une
adresse c'est ça parce que on peut
parfois il ya parfois d une race qui
heureusement permettent de retrouver qui
a déposé ces cétacés
mais il faudrait changer un peu
gestation mais les pièges photo dans la
campagne voyez les petits pièges photos
qu'on y utilise les chasseurs mais mais
devant la justice une photo qui a été
prise à l'insu de quelqu'un d'autre
et en plus par une collectivité voilà
c'est pas c'est pas recevable ah oui
aujourd'hui il faudrait changer ça il ya
plusieurs choses qu'il faut changer je
pense que pour les professionnels
aujourd'hui un professionnel il fait
payer à son client un pourcentage sur sa
facture pour l'élimination des déchets
moi je pense qu'il faut échanger des
réglementations voir ça avec nos députés
peut-être prendre 30% à la commande 40%
à la fin des travaux et et le sol note
le professionnel fournir à l'attestation
comme quoi il est bien revenu en
décharge des déchets responsabiliser il
faut l'encadrer pour ça c'est vrai qu'il
ya des sanctions quand même alors il ya
des sanctions qui sont prévus mais que
comme le disait fini ils sont
inapplicables
elles sont peu appliquées on a du mal on
a du mal à retrouver les auteurs des
faits surtout effectivement quand ce
sont des professionnels parce qu'il faut
il fonce à la nuit de façon de façon
très discrète
il ya l'histoire des caméras on avait
évoqué la question avec la gendarmerie
effectivement il faut faire une
déclaration en préfecture pour que la
caméra puisse être autorisé donc tout ça
et tout ça est très compliqué nous sur
versailles grand parc pour tout le
personnel particulier enfin le public
particulier on a une campagne de
sensibilisation ne rendait pas vos
déchets sauvages donc voilà pour le
pour le professionnel il faut taper plus
fort il faut vraiment un
il faut vraiment aller aller le
rechercher et puis et puis mettre les
amendes parce que c'est le seul langage
qu'ils puissent être compris et fini ce
temps à raison cette puisqu'il ya de
cette prime aux déchets vous aurez la
donne et que si on est sûr que qu'ils
ont été déposés là où il faut 20
effectivement si ça représente 30 % sur
la facture
regardez mais pour ça il faut mettre
faut mettre un système en place pour que
des filières où puissent accéder donc
les professionnels
et puis qu'ils puissent se faire donner
une attestation quand ça c'est là il ya
la population et parfois et évidemment
les gens qui font n'importe quoi mais il
ya une majorité peut-être de la
population qui est sensible à ça parce
qu'après tout c'est l'environnement dans
lequel on vit j'ai vu que la carrières
sous poissy y avait déjà une
une pétition qui avait recueilli pas mal
de 7 ou 800 signatures de gens qui se
mobiliser contre les déchets sauvages
est-ce que ça aussi c'est une piste pour
les verts que vous êtes parce que encore
une fois au poste vous êtes c'est
difficile de lutter seul contre contre
ça est-ce que essayer de mobiliser la
population c'est une piste possible
oui on sait ce qu'on sait ce qu'on
cherche à faire et c'est vrai que quand
on quand on gère cette compétence des
déchets on consacre une bonne partie
de l'argent à de la prévention à des
actions effectivement qui permettent en
amont et bien de prévenir ces choses là
alors après après c'est difficile aussi
d'avoir deux des informations concernant
les sur les hauteurs de deux de ces
faits mais qui avaient souvent que la
gombe ille-et-vilaine vais retrouver la
vraie s'il a renvoyé les déchets alors
c'est bon coller mon collègue de vélizy
l'a fait aussi avec pascal thévenot
et donc il a il a eu il a obtenu gain de
cause en justice puisque la personne
l'avait attaqué en justice
il a obtenu gain de cause mais il nous
dit soyez très prudents ne rentrait pas
au domicile peut être mais effectivement
il n'a pas été condamné
et donc c'est une c'est une sorte de
victoire parce qu'il avait pu enfin
retrouver l'auteur des faits l'auteur
voilà et mais on voit quand même qu'il
ya dans les difficultés que vous pouvez
avoir l'un et l'autre en tant que maire
il ya un peu un manque d'action et le
manque de volonté de l'état dont c'est
difficile où un peu vite
oui mais enfin c'est difficile sûrement
que c'est sans doute difficile va pas
dire un manque de volonté de l'état mais
en tous les cas il ya un manque de
moyens simples moyens
ça sert à ça c'est clair est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas aidé alors rien du tout moi
je suis moi je suis une commune qui est
en bord de seine en aval du barrage de
méricourt et je reçois sur les berges de
ma commune tous les ans des centaines de
tonnes de déchets donc moi j'ai pris ça
en charge avec les habitants et on y
associer les intronisations donc et
depuis dix ans on nettoie les berges
tous ensemble on a fermement festif tout
c'est un peu la bride et pour le coup ça
marche bien bon alors des fois on est un
peu on a un peu désabusé quand on voit
c'est tout ce qui nous arrive comme
l'hiver dernier mais parfois la met
mais on a on a eu quand même beaucoup de
solidarité la région nous a aidés la
mairie de paris ne nous est dévoyée sur
des sujets comme ça il y aurait beaucoup
de dignité mais les habitants tous les
cas se sont réappropriés les berges de
seine
et voilà on travaille beaucoup avec les
enfants je pense que l'éducation des
parents se fait souvent par les enfants
c'est ce que je disais aussi ça fait
partie aussi de la qualité de vie des
gens fin donc choisi d'habiter là c'est
aussi parce qu'il ya des paysages
magnifiques
il ya des berges magnifique et c'est
dommage de dessiller quoi donc donc
c'est pour ça que s'ils se mobilisent
c'est vrai que de la part de l'état à
l'aide il faut il faut bien le dire
pour autant on doit saluer l'action de
la région effectivement qui a mis en
place il ya un fond propreté nous qui
nous a permis qui va nous permettre de
faire un aménagement en bordure de la
plaine pour empêcher que si vous voulez
pour mettre des barrières des caméras et
des choses comme ça donc il ya un petit
peu d'être de la région mais c'est
difficile c'est dans le cadre de nos
compétences dans le cadre de notre
pouvoir de police du maire
c'est pas simple face à j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure de l'office national des
forêts yahia des déchets qui sont
déposées dans la forêt de saint germain
et l'office à face donc c'est l'état un
peu un débat nous on peut plus rien
faire contre exemple ils ont baissé les
bras on l'a reçu effectivement un
courrier où tu as dû le recevoir aussi
philippe
avant les vacances nous nous indiquant
que le budget consacré au dépôt sauvage
étant épuisé il n'allait plus d'ici la
fin de l'année
continuez sélecter voilà donc ça c'est
un vrai c'est un vrai problème c'est un
vrai problème parce que je parlais de la
plaine mais la forêt également est très
impacté et de salsa c'est vraiment
regrettable
il faut absolument trouver des budgets
en plus on sait que quand il ya un dépôt
sauvage si les partir immédiatement
c'est en appelle d'autres
donc sans ça on appelle d'autres oui
bien sûr et oui et 15-0 d'envoi on le
laisse des gens se disent heureux d'être
là et ça il faut vraiment des solutions
pérennes pour sortir de ça sinon on va
arriver dans des situations comme on l'a
connu sur la sueur triel et sur carrière
de la population et il ya en effet les
déchets qui sont vus par les individus
il ya les entreprises vous avez des
relations vous avec votre père avec des
entreprises pour essayer de les
sensibiliser à ça ou c'est compliqué
parce qu'on sait pas lesquelles les lois
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué parce que
c'est pas ne s'est pas de notre premier
notre premier public c'est vrai que le
premier public et et on va dire 90% du
travail et est consacré sur les
collectes des déchets ménagers des
ordures ménagères et c'est vrai que ça
nécessiterait notamment peut-être un
travail peut-être avec la chambre de
commerce peut-être que les représentants
effectivement vous avez raison pour
sensible et sensibilisé à cette
promenade problématique de déjà parce
que pour conclure quelle solution vous
voyez à 7 cette question alors il ya un
peu de
lutter contre les incivilités évidemment
mais est ce qu'il ya des solutions plus
plus radicale au plus radicales il faut
renforcer les peines et les peines assez
sociale sont pas assez fortes
il faut aider des élus et les former
pour qu'ils puissent exercer
correctement leur pouvoir de police au
pendant plus que les clos maire du petit
village du coin se transforme en shérif
et court après tout le monde donc ça va
mieux à ses noces aperçoit plus voilà
donc il faut on nous on fait déjà un
travail avec la gendarmerie
sur tous ces sujets là j'avoue que chez
nous on est au début on est bien aidé on
travaille avec le colonel bara ce que
j'ai vu tout à l'heure
voilà on est aidé par par les gens là
mais il faut ce qu'ils font ce qu'ils
peuvent
ils sont comme nous aussi ils disent ils
viennent ils peuvent que constater que
j'étais chez vous constatez voilà oui on
est voilé mais a baissé parce que si on
prend pas les gens sur le fait moi je
pense qu'il faut changer les règles
comme je le disais tout à l'heure par
rapport aux facturations des entreprises
celle ci propose piste voilà il faut
augmenter le nombre de déchetteries
professionnelles il faut qu'ils puissent
accéder
quitte à changer nos déchetteries qui
accueille aujourd'hui que les
particuliers mais un particulier qui
rénove sa maison il vient avec une
camionnette dans une déchetterie on le
compare un professionnel et on accepte
pas oui alors être assouplies imaginez
le galibot ce que le week-end sur scène
mais dans l'île mais ça n'apporte la
camionnette allées pleines on veut
vendre on refuse qu'ils la mettent à la
déchetterie il faut à ça si je
peux pas le mettre n'importe où donc ça
il faut changer il faut changer ces
règles là qu'on est des filières de
recyclage
quand quelqu'un vient avec des plaques
de fibrociment dans une déchetterie faut
pas qu'on lui dise même si on voulait
prend pas il faut qu'on lui trouve la
solution
mais ça se voit c'est pour faciliter
aussi d'ateliers et il faut que quand
même les lieux
les élus
moi je fais partie d'une communauté
urbaine sur gps et eau
historiquement on était une petite
communauté d'agglomération de 5000
habitants et on est sur le territoire
complètement à l'ouest et intelligemment
le président de l'époque avait fait une
convention pour que les trois quatre
communes qui était à l'ouest à y accéder
à la déchetterie de la communauté de
communes quasi là je viens d'apprendre
que les deux communautés
quand tout d'accord ne sont plus
d'accord ce qui fait qu'on a pu on a put
déchetterie mais habitant n'iront jamais
faire 15 km traversé mantes la jolie
donc c'est facile il faut qu on se met
ça va c'était un peu la vie des citoyens
comme ça il faut un peu de bon sens et
aussi changé peut-être les règlements
merci merci infiniment mcdowell merci
infiniment philippe dje cela et voilà
puis on peut dire bonjour
soyez un peu plus civique quoi merci
beaucoup
[Musique]